j'ai pas pu voir la partie moi j'aime la
repasser rapidement puis en plus à nous
permettre de la revoir coup par coup
parce que c'est vrai que les cours
arrivent à peu en grappe
ok bon c'est un genre de sicilienne
cannes et maxime qui envoie du g4 g5
voix maximy vacui qu'un de toute façon
il ya quatre parties donc
donc il ya le temps on va suivre cette
game maxime tu veux ramener le cavalier
on dessine co
tranquillement tranquillement il va y
avoir le cas et qui va venir en trois
pions des 5 c'est magnifique ah bah il
va falloir clic 1 pour maxime à la il
fait sa petite tête de maxime qui sourit
arriva juste cliquer en fait il va faire
tour ff4 je pense qu'il est venu pour
cliquer autorisa gars qui cliquent aussi
un cdu 15 + 2 il clique fort aussi au
bras je crois trop allez hop il en a
absolument rien à [ __ ] de la tacc des
touristes saga il est tranquille il veut
juste on voyait des punto aulas le
vénézuélien voilà c'est trop en cinq
minutes sur ce coup tu peux pas te
réfléchir est bon il est pas content
mais monte à une position merde c'est
vrai fallait réfléchir avant sinon c'est
complexe là ce qui nous fait historique
zagat la position paraît difficile 1 h 5
g si ça arrive vite si tu repas bah tu
vas te prendre du f fois trop dans la
tronche à ses savates ouvrir le centre
cavalier e cette bombe à maxime va
cliquer h5 en fait c'est sûr lecavalier
a eu 7 bras qui colmate de trois cases
mais
il a fait cavalier f5 bon salaire très
bien aussi cavaliers pro f 5 e f ça
touche le foufou prend pions prend il ya
aussi ce qui arrive est sûre rock qui va
faire h5 ça peut ça peut faire un stop
ce match ça peut vraiment faire un deux
et demi à 1 2 me est donc là il va
envoyer h5 maxime c'est sûr et qui va
aller lui ouvrir le roi
et il envoie h5 il semble être premier
quand même maximin parce qu'il va
pouvoir créer avec g6 la rupture sur
l'époux une toge pour ouvrir les
colonnes devant le roi du touriste zagat
qu'est ce qui fait en fait historique
zagat mais je passe juste cliquer en
fait il faut juste cliquer en fait à ce
jeu il n'a pas compris en fait eduardo
prise f5 écarts et les dessins qu il a
pas l'air bien il va se prendre un f6
non juste partie catastrophique indique
torride zagat
si maxime qui se dit je vais repartir en
siesta l'intérêt quand on joue les rocks
opposé c'est d'être le premier qui
touche le trio de pions adverse et la
maxime le touch avec apsys partie
extrêmement facile de maxime donc
cavalier afrique at il touche un peu
pense pas qu'on mette la dame a eu
quatre pour pas donner un tempo avec des
cinq mais un juste un coup comme dame g4
peut-être juste 1 dames g4 faut prendre
cette dame f5 g6 qui peut arriver vous
d'alger 4 comprend un système f3 nombre
enfin il ya tout qui gagne la musique at
ça a vraiment l'air fort après maxime a
raison de prendre son temps puisque a
peut-être des variantes où il réussit à
échanger les dames et ils donnent que 1
ou 2 punto shdm et la finale sera
gagnante pour maxime des 500 way
mesdames e4 pas des cinq direct il va
faire j'ai six avants et des cinq après
juste dire que tu veux pas te mettre
dans du d5 malheureusement je ne peux
pas réagir avec le chat trop de délai
mais d'un métro d'alger cade du coup est
plus logique en quelque sorte que du
coup s'il fait g6 battu sur badra pas de
temps quoi tu te mets pas dans du d5
dalle va peut-être faire des cinq quand
même pour essayer de faire 4 way le
problème c'est qu'il lui manque deux
trois tempo il aurait les pions à 4 et
b4 il serait en train déjà de faire à 3
il aurait peut-être dû contre jeux et
des chances mais mais là il ya trop de
retard il va se prendre tourache quatre
tours h1 tu comprends j'ai six tours
prend h7 ça va trop vite en fait je
pense qu'il va attendre pour prendre
maxime parce qu'il veut pas laisser la
case f7 pour la tour la seule gloire de
la position noir c'est peut-être cette
tour à sept qui défend h7 et cavaliers
en f4 qui défend g6 ok il a mis un vrai
17h défensif touriste zagat ce qui a un
beau miracle un de sa part il a vraiment
raté son ouverture ok donc on voit que
maxime à toutes ces pièces sur le rock
il a sacrifié une qualité pendant qu'on
faisait ce petit ce petit changement en
f4 mais bon on voit que que le roi noir
est aux abois là la menace ça va être
fou pranger 6 d'un match 8 ya f4 f5
aussi qui peut partir
puis à plus de temps mais donc là et
menace arrive ne vous prends qui on
prend d'arâches 8 bref cette tour à je
suis 3,6 d'un point 8 puis tour f 7
tours france et 7 pardon
qui joue cavalier 5
pour défendre et attaquer
quatre dames c4
alors maxime attention maintenant s'ils
bougent le fouillis fait changer les
dames
derrière content de ses couilles torride
zagal a bien joué de la part des
touristes zagat je sais pas s'il veut
jouer un coup comme cavalier d2 mais il
fera il fera dam des quatre probablement
et to ride zagat saddam peut encore
revenir en f7 donc fait cavalier à 5
donc sur dame c'est cette île doit
vouloir faire food et 5 et sur damev
cette tour d un probablement pour
vraiment foncer le fou sur la case des 5
il est pas bien eduardo après difficile
de juger de cette partie 2 et d'edward
obs qui s'est mis vraiment il était
vraiment été très vite très mal donc
cavalier f3 alors il veut quoi il veut
qu'ils avalent et c4
dont déjà sur fou prend il veut dame
prend tout reprend et tourer maths et
cavaliers ces quatre cavaliers h4 qui a
validé si ce tour des huit
food et 5,3 et fuite
au kef où des 5,3 et fuite il va devoir
faire
et cavaliers de 3 donc cavalier f5 forcé
qui a valu à cinq a l'air d'être le seul
coup comment est ce qu'on gagne un prix
cavaliers f5 c'est sûr qu'on peut le
faire je vous assure que j'ai pas le
gain aya cavaliers prendrions pranger si
on prend acte courageux fuite maths
c'est terminé qu'est ce que c'est bien
joué de la part de maxime vue à la
vitesse de la lumière
g6 et tour h8 mat du coup il a fait tout
un foin f3 et on prend 2,3 et cavaliers
5 ils essayent d'attaquer ou trois ya
quoi matériel mans 1 2 3 4 5 et un pion
de plus pour maxime et une position
écrasante
et ben voilà ça va faire punto ça va
faire 1 0 je vois pas maxime raté une
finale aussi simple là il veut 4 pour
enfermer le cheval carrément on n'arrive
même plus à lui trouver de caser sa
bande on va écouter ça fait 1 0 pour
maxime et ça fait très plaisir allez sa
part on va voir ce qui va jouer avec les
blancs
ils to ride zagat
il tente ça
va voir ce que maxime répond ça va pas
jouer la prépa des candidats ça c'est
sûr
il compte pourquoi ce tournant au hasard
rien bah c'est le czech comme global
championship donc c'est un tournoi qui
pas qu'ils comptent pour rien en fait
c'est qui compte pour ça en fait j'ai
pas trop comment dire
il est il est suffisant à lui-même en
fait s'il n'est pas intégré dans un dans
un plus gros tableau quoi en fait il est
facile et la cua il vit suisse avis donc
à ces ouvertures un peu bizarre avec le
h4 ça retombe dans des genres de benoni
avec h4 c'est un peu bizarre est
difficile à expliquer parce que c'est
pas des coups normaux mais en gros tu
espères retomber dans une structure
benoni etc le h5 hausse car je crois 3
shinko soit fort hockey maxime qu'à une
position correcte ici va falloir réussir
à taper sur les cases il veut faire a6b
cinq c4 jouer sur sa majorité ça retombe
dans une baie noni bizarre où exactement
dont cavaliers h7 il va développer les
pièces s'est départi aa3 résultats
ont ils développent en fait parler ses
positions qui sont vraiment bizarre je
rappe première vue c'est vraiment mieux
pour les noms pour les mois je
préfèrerais jouer avec les noirs en fait
mme en fait c'est mieux pour les blancs
je t'ai fait tellement de trous mais en
fait tu contrôles bien le centre tu peux
pas faire petit rock qui peut pas
vraiment faire grand roque mais ça joue
vraiment sur l'espace quand il se met à
l'abri ben justement faty fpt des fois
ils font même roi et feu dans ces trucs
là
et tout revient et il garde le roi un
peu bizarre leur tour en
h16 avait plu est fou de cases blanches
après elle pourrait repasser par âge 3 7
tours c'est un peu particulier c'est
très bizarre a joué donc cavalier d1
alors qu'est ce qu'il veut faire avec
car l idée un j'en sais rien parce qu'il
doit vouloir revenir en trois pour a
lancé quatre mais le cavalier va arriver
à 1,5 ça a l'air assez catastrophique ça
a l'air d'être très mal joué paris to
ride zagat cavaliers 5 et contrôler les
contrôles c'est qu'à toi ça a vraiment
l'air way s'est trompé ituri zagamé
après ces genres de position le redis il
adore les blancs mais concrètement
comment tu joues si tu fais petit rock
adam prend h4
si tu fais grand roque tu te prends b5
soit c'est très dur un ace et 4 ans et 4
france et 4 mai à palmarès il vient de
jouer il vient de jouer quatre ou cinq
coups pour pour revenir au même
c'est
juste mal joué en fait valoir leur
banger nom très très beau format
magnifique avec les tours qui passe
comme ça surtout la finale lorsqu il
restera huit joueurs là la phase finale
finale va être cool là on est encore
dans les qualifs mais mais la phase du
premier os sur l'axé du 2 au 7 novembre
de mémoire ça va être vraiment sympa
donc à 5 mai à wayne on là le problème
c'est que pommes pourries torride drag
en fait ce qui n'a pas de casque pour
son roi et que lecavalier h7 contrôle g5
je pense maxime baffert fouet 6 il va
juste aller ramasser le pion en fait
c'est tout à fait dans le style maxime
esque
cavaliers f6
c'est bien aussi parce que ça attaque 4
il veut provoquer f3
et peut-être qu'il fera foulées saint
caprais pour échanger le fou fou b5
c'est ce qui vient de se passer ouais
non mais c'est juste c'est trop malgré
la connexion de maxime qui est pas
terrible il a que une barre vous pouvez
pas le voir mais maxime a que une barre
de connexion mais ouais non c'est trop
trop dur trop dur à jouer cavalier 17 on
dit généralement que dans les penno ni
il faut échanger deux pièces et là c'est
ce que maxime a réussi à faire il a
échangé pile poil 2 pièces et du coup il
est il est extrêmement bien je pense
qu'il va prendre ses 4 et cavaliers 17
personnellement ça a l'air d'être la
meilleure solution ouais dans les
structures benoni quand on échange de
pièces après on commence à voir toutes
les cases la raison c'est qu'on a plus
le problème d'espacé un côté côté noir
on a moins de pièces et du coup là il va
pouvoir rentrer sur toutes les cases
noires alors c'est un peu contre
intuitif de dire que les cases noires
que le foot qu'anouar et le bon fou
parce que maxime allais pions sur cases
noires et son adversaire à les pions sur
case blanche donc le foot des blancs en
f4 est censé être le bon fou et le fou
g7 est censé être le mauvais fou mais là
le truc c'est qu'en fait on vous voyez à
trop de trous sur cases noires et le fou
peut pas tout les combler s'ils auraient
la même position avec un pion aux cinq
la position serait vraiment bonne pour
les blancs mais le problème c'est que
comme y'a pas de pion aux cinq dans le
fouillis va pouvoir naviguer sur les
cases noires alireza partie venant
alireza lui se concentre vraiment sur
sur les tournois réels meiway la lapin
c'est juste que tu sais pas où mettre
ton roi si tu fais petit rock adam prend
h4 encore que la thyroïde d'un proche
catcheur hulk ou g5 mais bon là ça va
être dames 5 1 qui va rentrer pour dame
prend b2 peut-être arriver peut-être
dameuse 5-fu f4 dams est touché 5 après
maxime peut aussi faire ça hein en fait
match nul pour maxime c'est pas mal bon
il fait froid m6 il veut il veut en
découdre mais match nul serait pas ce
serait pas une mauvaise chose ce ne
serait pas un mauvais résultat chez sia
de temps longue ici le tata steel en
janvier j'ai l'impression que les
calendriers vide en fin d'année
alors il va y avoir des compétitions
intéressantes déjà je crois que c'est du
25 au 30 octobre ou c'est du 25 7 25 au
30 septembre où 25 au 30 octobre en tout
cas il va y avoir le championnat du
monde de 960 je vois que c'est du 25 au
30 octobre mais je me suis mis un doute
là après y aura la finale de ce tournoi
qui sera du 2 au 7 novembre donc qui
sera qui sera aussi sympa et il y aura
le championnat du monde de rapides et
blitz fin décembre et il y aura notre
compétition l'exam liszt aussi 20
novembre 10 novembre donc tu auras il y
aura quelques compétitions sympa après
en longues
il y aura weick en janvier fait le
calendrier très mal foutu un depuis
longtemps les tournois sont un peu
ramassé les uns sur les autres mais mais
ce sera ce sera en janvier après on n'a
pas encore l'annnonce du circuit grande
chaise tour qui sera qualificatif pour
le candidat l'année prochaine donc on
sait pas trop encore et je crois pas
qu'ils aient date encore pour la coupe
du monde ni pour le match de championnat
du monde d'ailleurs qui sont quand même
important ouais maxime et maxime et
tranquille à la position est vraiment
belle il va faire tout reprend des six
tours b 8 il va taper en b2
fou prend instantanément maintenant
il va reprendre de a j'imagine 32f
donnerait la case 5 c'est trop
ami prendre ces terribles qui avait
progressiste on bouge h4 et dame prend
2,4 au cul oui bon ça va faire 2 0 l'as
apparaît en revanche attention à le
match contre séville en sera beaucoup
plus difficile là vous le sentez on est
tous très tranquille parce que la
différence de niveau est stratosphérique
déjà de base mais en plus cela la
première partie était déjà
très avantageuse pour maxime après à
peine cinq minutes de jeu bon et là la
deuxième partie il est vraiment en train
de faire l'écart donc ils évitent lead
avec h4 mais maintenant le problème
c'est qu'ils donnent la case 5 et
regardez le cavalier j'ai 3 10 to ride
zagar il a pas de case il est pris dans
le pion
ce cavalier il est pris dans les
pouilles tôt et c'est le cavalier de
maxime qui prend là la priorité pourquoi
qui fait pas le tournant il n'a pas
voulu tenter la phase de qualif bas
qu'il aime pas les tournois sur internet
en dix minutes ça n'intéresse pas il
préfère pas joué ils se contentent ils
aiment bien les blitz et les belettes
sur internet il n'aime pas trop les
cadences plus longue donc là ouais
maintenant on voit un ces visuels
maximas cavaliers qui est magnifique en
a eu cinq qui protège à vii donc y aura
jamais de jeu la casa ficelle est
inaccessible pour le cavalier il peut
pas rentrer dessus donc les noirs en une
case pour le cavalier les blancs non et
en gros ça va juste suivre comme ça ça
va être ton plan b 6 tours b 8 dames 17
tours prend b2 grosso modo alors après
on peut aussi passer la tour peut-être
en b 4 voire même en b3 gens faire
tomber 8 tomber trois tours b 8 tourbe
est retombé 4 et dames 17 sa part axa
gagne tout seul je sur est encore un
petit peu au noir parce que il ya
toujours des magouilles possible mais on
n'oublie pas que c'est maxime avec les
noirs c'est pas la même chose il fait
cavalier h1 du coup pour essayer de
revenir bon an mal an vers rêve de
détroit il veut revenir en d3 c'est un
joli chemin là prix pareils torride zag
assez bien joué 1 c'est ce qu'il fallait
faire
et
moi ça interdit cavaliers detroit et on
va ramener tourbe et 4 dames 17 comme
annoncé précédemment
il a déjà à 0 0 avant le début du match
c'était dur pour historique zagat mais
alors là à 2 0 pour maxime alors il
commence par tours 1 pour essayer
d'amener la dame en bessette en premier
maxime peut aussi jouer tour 8b 6 passes
et la dame puis tours b 4 je pense que
c'est l'option que maxime va choisir la
tour 1 ira peut-être en a deux pour
défendre le pion mais bon on va pas
inventer
un suspense qui n'existe pas dans ce
match on est dans la partie qu'est ce
qui s'est passé dans maxim a mis le pion
c4 qui l'a doublé comme prévu il tape
avec la dame en a 7 donc maxime qui
continue à faire avancer sa position
très tranquillement
il peut échanger les dames il peut les
garder il peut peut-être essayer d'aller
des cas les vergers 4000 après enlève
deux armées la tour en b3 cavaliers d1
on voit quand même la marche que maxime
a par rapport à un joueur à à 26 50 il
remporte quand même c'est parti très
facilement il n'y a même pas de
absolument aucun suspense c'est grand
maître contre amateurs maxime air de
bien se faire chier bas c'est trop
simple en fait pour lui quand je vous
disais le tour suivant contre sam sevian
il va le prendre très au sérieux parce
que c'est un joueur qui est déjà en
capacité de l'éliminer
alors maxime est loin devant mais bon ça
peut il ya bien un danger c'est l'heure
de la sieste ah bah oui 14 heures c'est
l'heure de la sieste à un très
clairement je passe ithurritze zagat va
vraiment tenter quelque chose dans la
troisième 6 va laisser faire une nulle
facile parce que ça me saoule
intéressant de voir ça d'ailleurs
maxime qui prend b2 ils échangent contre
le pion à 4 mais juste regarder les
pions 1 regardez ces quatre contre cinq
les mets en les bleus contre les verts
ils sont bloqués grâce aux cavaliers qui
qui m'a qui bloque le pion aux oeufs en
fait et du coup regarder les noirs ils
ont le pion c'est qu'ils avancent et les
blancs ils ont deux pions de bloquer une
violation à 3m suffisent ils gagnent oui
nul sur la troisième et le match serait
terminée
tomber 3 pour maxime va probablement y
avoir un tour c'est un pour mettre le
cavalier en c3 après peut encore sauver
nul un peu dans cette partie là
évidemment maxime peut plus perdre mais
les blancs pas de pions - tu bloques
encore
ça doit être foutu mais tu as encore un
peu de nul dans ton règne
pour 3,1 éleveurs cavaliers c3 c'est le
seul coup sinon c'est tout reprend 1,4
au prochain mais quelle c3 il doit y
avoir cavaliers detroit
pour ces deux
cavaliers b 4 tours c1
ça défend encore pour ituri zagat donc
tour ces deux maxime va probablement
faire tour eu un échec rouages de et
cavaillon cinq retours pas encore
terminée on voit d'ailleurs qu'il a à
vous voyez pas les les pseudos de chasse
comme il a bien le drapeau vénézuélien
encore un historique zagat sa chance
envoyé un coup qui s'inhale où es tu on
nous dit dans le tchat ce qui peut
tenter cavale et b5 pour aller toucher
des 6
séries ce match à deux et demi parce que
c'est en quatre parties en fait la
cinquième je crois que c'est c'est le
tie break il le laisse dedans maxime qui
peut échanger les tourelles et faire car
et les f2 qui a valu aux quatre déjà
pour gagner un point d'eau voilà c'est
ce qui va faire
ça fait déjà un pion
et peut-être ça va en faire un deuxième
j'avais laissé 3 qui avait les prendrait
5 et ça ce serait douche pau et auch
bref si c'est bien aussi un pion prend
car elle les prend il va les prendre le
plus moche tout pareil
à y fait même à y croire et 7 3 6
3 au 5
et ça en fait deux et ça fait 2 0 maxime
qui se lève et qui se barre ouais trop
facile pour maxime trop facile
même pas de frissons un an c'est parti
ouais c'est un gouffre même peut-être
2,3 gouffre qui les sépare et envoyer
tous risa gars qui est dépité
déjà qu'il avait pas trop de doutes sur
l'issue du match l'a20 il n'y a plus
aucun espoir
maxime à qui joue un petit p 3
alors là c'est ça c'est vraiment des
gosses qui est en train de faire maxime
ouais c'est vraiment dégueu l'ouverture
de maxime trop de trous mais bon il veut
pas jouer il veut pas jouer ces
ouvertures il joue à larache il est trop
facile une des deux suffisent à une
nulle sur les sur une des sur salat ou
la prochaine ça fait gagner le match
donc bombe doit pas être très stressés
ils joueraient pas pareil s'il y avait
un partout ça je peux vous le dire
prends le temps 50 pour maxime 13 20
pour ict warid zagat en fait dans la
première partie s'est mis à réfléchir un
peu trop tard quand il était déjà mal il
a dû vouloir jouer vite et il s'est dit
on va essayer de tenir le rythme de
maxime et ça un petit peu du lait chaud
des maximes qui doit peut-être hésité à
peut-être des fois tu veux faire cavaler
b d2 puis on prend et des quatre pour
ouvrir le fou à maxime là qui en fait
trop quand même dans les ouvertures
c'est trop
original ce qui joue après il s'occupait
du coup les gars qui vont enfin un coup
vite je reste treize minutes allaient
maxime il faut aller la chercher cette
qualif il prépare puis on prend et des
cats je pense pour ouvrir la position et
faire parler les fous mentoring saga qui
a décidé de se battre il veut mourir les
armes à la main penses tu vas prendre
des 5 et prendre des 5 et faire des
quatre fers des quatre direct il peut
pas on navigue garder la structure comme
ça il fait et 4 direct c'est la même
idée hein
c'est de s'ouvrir maxime qui regarde un
peu ses ongles il est peinard
prises des 4 prises des 4 ça ou la
position et b4 ça permet de garder la
casse ces quatre occupé par un pion et
ça donne pas au cheval ce que maxime va
se décaler en b2 avec la dame attention
si on échange les fous maxime pourrait
rester avec le move est fou contre le
bon fou ça pourrait être ça un
rapport matériel gênant j'imagine d'amd
2 à 3 bon ça ça va normalement jusqu'à
un échange à 5 puis on prend un pion
prend peut-être tu veux faire tout
reprendre à huit dames 3,8 et toi pour
se gagner la colonne à
paraît assez logique ce qu'on peut dire
c'est une occasion de progresser brenon
il veut jouer parce qu'ils jouent mais
qui joue contre maxime tu te dis pas que
ça te fait enfin aux échecs tu dis pas
que tu veux une partie pour te faire
progresser à ce niveau là il joue parce
qu'ils jouent mais il a peut-être une
chance sur dix mille encore de
d'égaliser dans le match et ils veulent
apprendre c'est tout quoi dire je suis
déjà là machin j'ai rien à faire de ma
journée je tente quand même ma science
on s'est jamais
amusé clic une déco elle va peut-être
prendre du fou du couvent pour pas
donner le tempo à la tour peut-être plus
mal à me prendre du fou mais il prend
vraiment beaucoup de temps pour chacune
deux des six de ses décisions
eduardo je pense qu'ils joueraient plus
vite contre un autre joueur
mais à la contre maxime c'est aussi le
nom qui fait peur puis les deux
premières parties la maxime qui a gagné
la colonna pourrait l'utiliser en jouant
tour à 4 un jour pour taper le piot un
tour à sept pour venir taper damas de
damas v veut il veut jouer le mauvais
fond conclut bons fous
bonjour en vrai c'est un bon joueur de
tout donner pour essayer de revenir
maxime qui se posent peut-être des
problèmes à lui même en jouant trop
facile c'est peut-être espèrent-ils to
ride zagar d'avoir un maxime qui voit
bayer qui voit comme ça très tranquille
il doit dire bon
il a gagné les deux premières mais il a
envie d'aller dormir maxime en tongs
chaussettes mais ça doit suffire il ya
quatre minutes d'avancé déjà
ça échange qualifié 5 et là il va
sûrement y avoir à eux cinq ils veut
dame
il veut dame g5 c'est peut-être bien
joué ça de la part des touristes zagat
ça c'est fort n'a donc c'est un vrai
avantage noirs ici il a fait h3
il veut se garder la casse pour le fou
l'ordinateur adore fou prend le 4 84 km
et trois cas y prend 1 mais c'est très
dur à voir parce qu'on n'aime pas
normalement faire cet échange je vous
sais si ça permet de contrôler la casa 4
c'est assez bien joué tu es là on voit
le problème de maximin c'est ce fou le
carré leva pour venir en d4 s'il le veut
il est bien placé en c5 tout ce qui est
relié à pas vraiment accès à des cinq on
n'arrive pas à échanger les fous maxime
peut perdre cette partie alors il a
vraiment joué en pantoufles celle là
juste y a pas de menace avec les blancs
les pièces mineurs réussissent pas à
s'installer dans le jeu alors que le fou
c'est cissé lecavalier ces cinq sont
très forts
faut dire il va peut-être venir en c2 ça
lui permettra de faire un genre de
focales
attention ça peut menacer carrier points
4 44
44 44 dame prend 1,3 puis on prend trois
fous prend 1,4 et c'est pour ça que le
fou est venu défendre ce qui va jouer
tour un
f3
donc moi ça me paraît
ça me choque pas qu'ils jouent eux qui
jouent très tranquille maxime après
c'est juste sur l'ouverture il aurait
peut-être dû être plus méfiant
et là et touristes à gary 101 qui peut
la gagner après il aura encore les
blancs il peut encore espérer
joueur espagnol d'origine vénézuélienne
après peut-être que maxime fait ça pour
les pubs un toujours important les pubs
il va il va se faire rentrer sur la
colonne à la partie est
difficile
si ce jeu revenir vers des 4 et ce qui
sera mieux placé
peut-être deux
bien sûr qu'il ya des cas du coup il se
fera pas toucher à ce que ces
volontaires de faire autant de compet
basse et lucratif et puis ça quand tu
fais une compet n'est pas obligés de la
gagner donc là je sais pas combien ont
gagné les joueurs au premier tour mais
ils sont peut-être déjà 4000 $ ou un
truc comme ça
adam detroit il veut peut-être x 4 on
voit que maxime essaye de tout donner
pour se concentrer sur dame t3 ya
peut-être aussi dame b 2 1 aujourd'hui
prose de faire cavalier 3 et d'aller
s'activer proche du roi adverse
forcément c'est le meilleur coût ainsi
le coût de l'ordinateur on va avoir un
c'est une option cavaliers ou trois pour
vite vite vite arriver il fait la même
chose avec cavaliers g3 ça lui donne
peut-être des cavs a lieu deux dans
certains
dans certains monde et c'est là qu'ils
touriste zagat va craquer et oui comme
souvent maxime quand ils s'activent il
fait mal c'est vrai qu'ils to ride zagat
va va craquer ou peut-être at-il déjà
craqué de laisser ce contre jeu à maxime
maître du contre jeu le joueur français
il a toujours un petit peu d'avancé
autant historique zagat qui a plus que 5
minutes maintenant c'est peu contre
maxime dans ce genre de position
maxime qui sifflote avril et il est très
très très très très facile maxime
et hisser là qui vient de mettre un coup
de pression monumentale eye to ride
zagat s'il tombe en dessous des 2
minutes avec ce coup là après il aura dû
beaucoup de mal à jouer s'il a une autre
décision difficile à prendre et à la
déjà quatre minutes 4 minutes 30 le
temps qui s'égrène l'ordinateur qui
prouve aux écoutes comme roy et fuite
peut-être pour revenir vers cette
protégée le pion ou damas est pour
gagner un tempo ici
peut-être même un coup comme damas est
intéressant pour venir un petit peu
touché la première rangée
le problème est assez que la décision
est difficile à prendre
et qu'il ne reste pas énormément de
temps à eduardo ça va être extrêmement
dur pour lui mais ce cavalier g3 il pose
des problèmes donc il fait g6
il veut empêcher cavaliers f5 mais
peut-être que maxime va maintenant venir
en e2 avec son cavalier
échanger les chevaux et faire un genre
de forteresse peut aussi décider juste
de temporiser en jouant un coup droit
a lieu devrait s'y perdra
le bénéfice de ce beau cavalier ça va ça
va rapprocher maxime de la nul
et donc de la qualification
et en plus ya peu de temps et contre 1
maxime quittions tendent des pièges à
gauche à droite
plongez les pions métro assure qu'il
prend b3 en fait il veut dame prendrait
six maxime
il va toucher le fou il va prendre 5
par an qui peut pas mais c'est que
pièces de maxime se sont réorganisés en
fait le cavalier couvre des cases et
donc il réussit pas vraiment sont
emparés de ce pion pour le moment
on le voit suez à la caméra il lève les
mains
il aimerait bien apprendre la victoire
maxime qui va prendre en d6
c'est chose faite
qui va passer prendre 5 maintenant
c'est trop
trop dur
qui a valu à 5 ça a l'air d'être un joli
coup
mais maxime d'après leur dis peut faire
nul direct peut faire d'amd 8,3 cette
dame et fuite avec un père pète
imparable c'est ce qui va faire
il peut pas faire rager sept îles se
feront dame prend des 5 et la dame et
fuite
et s'est terminé
il ya encore un échec en e3 mais le roi
va se cacher et maxime qui s'étire et
cif et dames 3 damas est tjrs adam prend
b4
et ce sera simplement punto de plus
et oui ça va qualifier sans aucun
problème
est terrible beaucoup trop fort maxime
il est écoeuré torride zagat eduardo
elle avait peut-être mieux à faire de sa
journée
que de se prendre une clé de bras et la
maxime qui va répéter un je vous annonce
professionnels ici
et maxime qui se qualifie pour le
prochain tour sans avoir sué la moindre
seconde beaucoup trop facile
là c'est la prochaine fois on peut
continuer à jouer endormi un maxime
j'aurais peut-être même pas besoin de se
réveiller peu joué depuis son lit on
verra ce que ça donne pour maxime pour
la suite je vous remercie d'avoir suivi
ce live et je vous dis à très bientôt
sur czech com/fr pour la suite de cette
compétition et l'avancé de maxime dans
le tableau ciao ciao